sommes nous avec alexis poulain
cofondateur de la revue le monde moderne
bonsoir lexique est cool un merci d'être
avec nous en direct à temps sur rt
france avoir 56 % des français ne font
pas confiance au gouvernement selon ce
sondage là on a entendu des français pas
contents mais vous verrez si je me
trompe alexis poulain mais on a le
sentiment que les français ne se rebelle
pas tellement les français pourtant
habitué à être plutôt râleurs on les
entend pas beaucoup il semble plutôt
accepter les règles de ce confinement
strict sens d'ailleurs espoir de sortie
pour l'instant 1
mais évidemment je crois que les
français sont responsables dans leur
grande majorité ils savent très bien ce
qu'ils ont à faire
limiter la propagation de ce virus pour
aider les soignants à ne pas avoir un
affût une vague supplémentaires dans les
dents les oeufs dans les hôpitaux
le problème c'est tout c'est toutes ces
injonctions contradictoires café
l'exécutif depuis ces dernières semaines
d'une semaine à l'autre il fallait aller
au théâtre pour soutenir l'activité des
spectacles et puis aller voter et puis
rester chez soi et ne surtout pu sortir
et puis une fois qu on reste chez soi on
avait le droit de faire un jogging on
n'a plus le droit de faire du jogging
entre 10h et 19h enfin on a l'impression
qu'on joue avec les français en fait en
leur demandant jacques a dit restez chez
vous jacadi vous pouvez sortir entre 10
et 12 heures jacadi fait ça à jacques
abadie donc ça fallait pas le faire
les français sont pas idiots ils voient
bien que par contre on les a pris pour
des idiots
c'est le cas de votre micro trottoir on
voit tous ces gens qui ont dit mais il
suffisait de nous dire la vérité on n'a
pas besoin de mensonges ci avait pas de
masque il fallait le dire mais fallait
dire aux gens faites des masques
débrouillez vous pour vous protéger
d'une mode façon au delà des gestes
barrières
sauf que le choix de l'exécutif et du
gouvernement ça a été de mentir pour
couvrir la pénurie la pénurie de moyens
de masquer la pénurie à l'hôpital bien
entendu la pénurie de test et maintenant
on se retrouve et que c'est une
situation du confinement que les
français respectent tout en étant quand
même très circonspect avec le risque que
cette sortie de confinement soit à
retarder et que la sortie soit terrible
pour notamment l'activité économique
alors vous me croyez pas si bien dire
alexis pour l'un puisque dans le même
moment
en direct l'elysée annoncé l instant que
le prolongement du confinement irait au
delà du 15 avril à emmanuel macron qui
devrait s'exprimer demain mais aussi
lundi sans toujours tout vent en évitant
la question du déconfinement ça comment
peuvent le vivre les français sachant
que nos voisins européens eux commencent
à élaborer quand même les des stratégies
de déconfinement et c'est une politique
totalement improvisée c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas de stratégie on voit on voit en
fait l'inanité l'impéritie de ce
gouvernement dans cette crise on a
affaire à des néo manager des gens qui
sont des rh qui viennent du privé qui
n'ont pas le sens de l'état ni la
stature d'homme d'état pour gérer une
crise majeure
et qu'est ce qu'ils font et bien il gère
le court terme
donc on va faire quinze jours puis on va
refaire quinze jours c'était le choix de
faire comme en angleterre
eh bien on va attendre de voir comment
ça se passe et puis les chiffres étant
tel qu'il va falloir ensuite adapté
plutôt que aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on
demande qu'est ce que demandent les
français de la planification de l'ordre
et de la clarté et surtout surtout de la
sincérité
oui le déconfinement on peut y penser
dès maintenant ces mêmes urgent d'y
penser dès maintenant pour ne pas avoir
le retard qu'on a eu les russes ce soir
tout sur le territoire rappelez vous
c'était dans l'oise s'étaient dans le
grotesque avec quelques cluster vous
allez on appelait ça cluster à l'époque
mais au lieu de prendre les mesures qui
auraient été à l'époque qui aurait pu
sans doute éviter la propagation du
virus
on a attendu on a improvisé et
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on fait on
voudrait improvisé et ne pas planifier
la sortie du blond finement mais comment
vous dites ça à des patrons de pme
comment vous dites ça à des gens qui ont
besoin de travailler parce que sans ça
n'y a pas d'argent alors ok si vous
confiner les gens monsieur emmanuel
macron alors à ce moment là ces
moratoires sur les loyers que les gens
qui sont locataires n'est plus à payer
les loyers le temps du confinement
ces moratoires sur un paquet de trucs
sur les factures de gaz d'électricité
d'eau etc
si les gens ne peuvent pas travailler
alors ils ne doivent pas payer c'est
aussi simple que ça et si vous voulez
relancer l'économie il va falloir penser
déconfinement parce que ce qui va se
passer c'est des faillites massives de
pme alors oui effectivement les grandes
entreprises du cac 40
s'en fichent puisqu'ils ont des usines
qui tournent à peu près sur tous les
continents donc ils peuvent toujours se
rattraper
quand un pays va reprendre ça ira mais
pour les entreprises françaises qui sont
sur ce territoire qui n'ont que ça vous
êtes en train de mettre à la rue des
millions de français et dire que l'état
payera c'est simplement annoncé une
faillite générale c'est à dire que si on
ne relance pas l'économie si on ne fait
pas en sorte que l'on puisse simplement
organiser le retour à une vie normale
et pour ça il faut des masques il faut
des tests il faut des traitements
pourquoi pas revenir encore sur la
chloroquine on apprend qu'il va falloir
attendre fin avril pour avoir un
résultat sur l' enquête discovery on
aurait pu accélérer tout ça c'est à dire
que tout ce qui nous manque aujourd'hui
fait que la sortie du confinement va
être encore plus difficile pour tout le
monde on perd 6 points de pib
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que ce sera si on
a encore un mois de confinement mais je
n'ose même pas y penser
avec en plus des partenaires européens
qui ne jouent pas le jeu on est en plein
sommet européen on voit bien rien ne se
passe aujourd'hui sur la solidarité
européenne ne faut pas croire là-dessus
faut pas s'attendre à quoi que ce soit
donc aujourd'hui oui on doit parler
déconfinement on doit surtout le
planifier on doit surtout ne pas faire
l'erreur qui a été faite au début de
cette crise c'est à dire de naviguer à
vue
d'improviser le fait justement qu
emmanuel macron ne donne aucune date va
être prolongée 1 la gelée devant le nez
cette dépêche au delà du 15 avril
il s'exprimera lundi manuel macron après
20 heures pour présenter ses décisions
concernant cette lutte contre le
coronavirus qu'est ce que ça dit
effectivement comment vous la jugez
cette communication d'emmanuel macron
qui dans le même temps se rend en seine
saint denis sans masque avec des gens
agglutinés autour de lui c'est tout la
communication de mellac rond depuis le
début c'est à dire une mise en scène
tragique
rien ne se passe comme ça devrait il est
dehors dans la rue sans masquer ses
gardes du corps sont sans masque et
arrivent les badauds qui s'agglutinent
autour de lui et il dit respecter les
mesures barrières il se met en scène
avec des gens au balcon en joignant les
mains on parle de deux présidentes les
rois capétiens et autres
c'est du délire c'est à dire que on est
dans une communication spectacle mais
certainement pas dans une communication
de crise qui serait à la hauteur de
cette crise
aujourd'hui on a simplement quelqu'un
qui est en train d'essayer de masquer
les manquements de son gouvernement sous
couvert d'une guerre contre un ennemi
invisible une guerre qu'on n'est pas en
train de gagner parce que si on lit
l'art de la guerre de son souhait bien
emmanuel macron a tout faux et il ne
réussit pas en fait à mobiliser les
troupes il ne réussit pas à prévenir ce
qui sera l'étape d'après on est dans la
gestion de la deux en fait à à
retardement
plutôt que de prévoir c'est le cas
pourquoi pourquoi on ne veut pas parler
de déconfinement aujourd'hui parce qu'il
ya pas de plan tout simplement
donc on a pourquoi à quoi servent les
conseils de guerre à quoi servent tous
ces experts aussi docte s'ils sont
incapables de nous aider d'aider le pays
en fait à en sortir
cette communication hier qu'est ce
qu'elle montre elle montre bien
exactement ce que fait mal mâcon depuis
le début le en même temps je vous dis de
rester chez vous mais moi je sors je
vous dis protégez vous mais je ne me
protège pas je vais voir des soignants
leur demandant ce qu'ils leur manquent
ils disent à peu près tout mais je leur
apporte pas de masque ils arriveront dû
attendre jusqu'à fin juin pour avoir
tous les masques commandés en chine
donc c'est une mise en scène de
l'impossibilité de gouverner c'est une
mise en scène du nom pouvoir c'est une
mise en scène de l'incapacité c'est
triste c'est inquiétant c'est encore
plus inquiétant quand on ne donne pas de
date
quand on ne donne pas de cap quand
finalement on ne gouverne pas ce qui se
montre aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a un
président qui a été élu et qui est
incapable de gouverner
autre critique elle porte sur ce premier
tour des élections municipales qui s'est
tenue le 15 mars on a entendu beaucoup
de deux maires de communes dont tant
qu'ils avaient gagné au premier tour à
100% qu'ils demandent carrément
l'annulation de ce scrutin est ce que ça
peut être considéré selon vous comme une
faute politique du gouvernement macro
mais si c'était la seule mais évidemment
c'est une faute tragique
je suis allé voter beaucoup de français
sont allés voter on parce que on en
croit cette parole politique on croit à
un moment oui on dit qu'on peut aller
voter alors on va voter
on a pris toutes les précautions
nécessaires mais quand on voit le nombre
d'assesseurs le nombre de mères la façon
dont les bureaux certains bureaux n'ont
pas respecté
les mesures de protection on est devant
un scandale sanitaire majeur on est
devant une faute grave c'est à dire que
demandait aux français d'aller voter
sachant que deux jours après parce que
ne me faites pas croire qu on allait
prévoir comme ça du jour au lendemain
que le confinement arriverait deux jours
après le premier tour
sachant qu'il n'y aurait pas de deuxième
tour mais enfin c'est quoi cette
politique c'est ce que je vous dis sur 7
ha capacité de gouverner gouverner c'est
prévoir
emmanuel macron ne prévoit rien il est
fait pour simplement gérer c'est un
gestionnaire néo manager il est là pour
gérer en tant de noms crise quand tout
va bien pour faire du profit à court
terme il est banquier d'affaires voilà
ce qu'il fait quand on est un homme
d'état on doit prévoir et aujourd'hui on
a des gens qui sont simplement des
poulets sans tête qui court sans savoir
vraiment quoi faire et qui ont comme
priorité principale de sauver les
arrières et de dire c'est pas ma faute
j'ai fait tout ce qu'il fallait c'est
pas moi le responsable cette crise était
telle que je pouvais pas la prévoir
voilà le petit discours qui est en train
d'être sorti mais ils sont responsables
choisir la politique c'est choisir la
responsabilité vouloir s'en défausser
c'est scandaleux et on va voir des
commission parlementaire présidée par
richard ferrand les amis etc qui vont
les dédouaner bien entendu mais les
français ne sont pas dupes encore une
fois ils ont bien vu ce qu'il s'est
passé
des gens qui ont menti des gens qui ont
fait semblant des gens qui ont couvert
la pénurie le manque et qui les ont mis
en danger eux-mêmes eux et leur famille
et aujourd'hui c'est une crise beaucoup
plus large bien sûr on va pas accusé
uniquement le gouvernement mais on est
aujourd'hui dans un blocage qui
s'appelle le confinement mais c'est
simplement un blocage parce que on a été
incapable certains qui aurait pu prévoir
parce qu'ils sont élus pour prévoir
n'ont pas fait leur boulot tout
simplement merci beaucoup alexis est
pour lui un cofondateur de la revue le
monde moderne d'avoir été avec nous